[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
laurent gaudé bonjour je peux bien venu
sur ce plateau merci beaucoup d'être l'
écrivain prix goncourt votre dernier
roman est l'un des très beaux textes de
cette rentrée littéraire il est sorti à
quelques semaines à chez actes sud bien
sûr et il s'appelle chien 51 il est là
ce livre le chien du titre laurent gaudé
c'est le surnom que l'on donne aux flics
les quartiers pauvres d'une mégalopole
futuriste ultra à polluer qui s'appelle
magna paul détenu par un groupe privé ce
chien 51 ce flic qui vient d'une grèce
qui n'existe plus va enquêter sur un
meurtre sordide sur fond de trafic
d'êtres humains c'est un livre sombre va
y revenir mais ce sont surtout vos
premiers pas dans un genre que vous
aviez pas ou peu exploré jusqu'ici
qu'est la science fiction qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé c'est la question de
l'imagination en fait qu'imad qui
m'attirait c'est que dans la science
fiction on peut effectivement ce que
j'essaie de faire projeter un monde le
monde de demain et imaginer comment il
sera peuplé comment il fonctionnera
quels seront les objets qu'on utilisera
dans ce monde là tout ça c'est assez en
fait c'est assez fertile ça permet de
déployer son imagination et moi c'est
vrai que j'ai toujours eu une écriture
qui faisait appel à cette imagination
alors c'était souvent plutôt vaut pour
le passé ou mais là c'est vrai que c'est
en fait c'est assez amusant même si le
livret est sombre c'est assez amusant à
faire c'est on peut tout imaginer n'y a
pas de limite en fait je crois que cette
situation réelle mais futuriste que nous
avons vécu collectivement qui était la
pandémie de qobuz vous a encouragé dans
cette voie là pour deux raisons la
première c'est parce que je pense qu on
a vécu la science-fiction tous
collectivement si on nous avait dit
quelques années auparavant qu'on allait
vivre ça on aurait dit c'est un film
c'est pas possible donc ça on a traversé
la science fiction et puis je pense
aussi que ça a été pour beaucoup d'entre
nous un accélérateur de questions est ce
que c'est le monde dans lequel on va
vivre dorénavant est ce que c'est
vraiment ce dont on a envie pour nos
enfants ou les générations futures donc
toutes ces questions moi je les ai
reprise est un peu agité pour essayer de
construire ce livre le projet de la
firme qui détient la ville où se joue
l'intrigué assez
uniquement la rentabilité les six larié
qui sont une contraction entre citoyens
et salariés sont condamnés à une
existence quasi sans plaisir on pense au
meilleur des mondes deux axes clés on
pense à 1984 pour la surveillance
généralisée on a parfois en peut-être
les dessins de 1,6 bilal on pense à
matrix à barjavel est-ce que c'est tout
ça qui a nourrit votre image absolument
c'est toutes ces références là qui sont
aussi celles de ma génération je prends
sociable à leur honneur à des films
comme ça alors évidemment c'est toujours
des mondes un peu un peu de casser un
peu franchement on this topic ça je
crois que c'est aussi la règle du genre
c'est de proposer quelque chose de 2,2
dystopique pour aussi faire réagir est
ce que c'est bien vers ça qu'on a envie
d'aller je pense que c'est une des
possibilités mais ce n'est pas dit que
ça soit ça heureusement on peut rester
optimiste notamment parce qu'il ya
encore des tas de choses à faire pour
éviter que demain soit magna paul ouais
sauf que donc effectivement on parle
d'hyper connectivité d'ultralibéralisme
de contrôle policier à tout-va de
dérèglement climatique de
marchandisation des cordes fracture
sociale car la ville dans lequel se
passe à l'action est divisé en zones
quoi des classes et aux plus riches il
est quand même l'expression pas très
éloigné dans un monde qui ressemble un
peu à celui dans lequel on vit déjà oui
mais c'est moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est cet aller retour permanent entre
imaginer demain mais en fait c'est
beaucoup pour interroger aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'on passe son temps quand
on fait ça à se dire mais en fait ça ça
existe déjà simplement dans le livre on
le pousse un peu plus fort souvenez vous
des images des manifestations de hong
kong qui sont là aussi c'est de la
science fiction avec avec la
reconnaissance faciale pour essayer de
traquer les manifestants enfin on a
l'impression d'être dans un mauvais film
de sf je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
petits éléments qui appartiennent déjà
au monde d'aujourd'hui simplement là ils
sont réunies en une seule ville et de
manière un peu dramaturgique et ça vous
fait ça fait de vous quelqu'un de
foncièrement pessimiste
mais inquiet ça c'est sans nul doute
inquiet parce que j'ai l'impression que
les objets et le la technique la
technologie va tellement vite qu'on n'a
même plus le temps de se poser les
questions qui vont avec c'est ça le
problème c'est que les une espèce de
course vers le oui le la puissance des
objets et il faudrait quand même
ralentir un tout petit peu pour qu'on
puisse se poser les problèmes moraux
éthiques que propose chaque objet et
puis il ya une autre chose c'est que la
planète nous dit qu'il va falloir
changer de comportement or je n'ai pas
trouvé trace dans l'histoire d'un moment
où l'homme a été capable de renoncer à
ce qu'il avait inventé et ça c'est assez
préoccupant alors justement la dernière
fois qu'on s'est vus sur ce plateau
c'était au moment des élections
européennes le 2019 vous venez d'écrire
un long poème qui s'appelait qui
s'appelle l'europe banques et des
peuples un texte qui est peut-être
d'ailleurs la jeunesse de celui ci dans
lequel vous retrace y est l'histoire
chaotique de l'europe c'était bien sûr
avant la guerre en ukraine et vous
écriviez alors qu'il fallait je vous
cite sans cesser rappeler la cendre
l'appétit de destruction les deux
guerres mondiales la shoah la
colonisation
la préciosité de la paix apparaît
presque inaudible dont je rappelle qu'au
contraire que le que le notamment la
guerre en ukraine en ce moment nous nous
rappelle à quel point ce qu'on a pu
penser comme acquis pour toujours c'est
à dire vivre en paix dans une zone
prospère
c'est pas gagné ça nécessite ça
nécessite un travail permanent et
l'europe se construit aussi comme ça en
essayant de continuer à garder le cap de
cette boussole là qui est quand même
dans notre cas beaucoup axé sur les
libertés individuelles c'est la zone de
la terre ou où cette valeur là et c'est
pas la seule mais oui oui elle est
fortement souligné donc là aussi le le
monde de demain avec ces objets la
question des données personnelles tous
ces grands enjeux de réflexion sociétale
nous on a une va sûrement avoir une
manière européenne d'y répondre parce
qu'il faut qu'on reste bien campé sur
nos valeurs notamment celle de la
liberté individuelle la boussole dont
vous parlez
et on la retrouve dans ce livre comme
dans les autres votre oeuvre en général
est traversé de violence et de malheur
mais il ya quelque chose d'assez d'assez
commun à tous vos romans et vous écris
c'est la capacité des hommes à se tenir
debout quelles que soient les
circonstances ça vaut pour le roman ça
vaut pour l'actualité ça oui oui c'est
ce qui brille absolument c'est là où je
suis optimiste malgré tout malgré le le
monde parfois sombre que je déploie
c'est qu'il ya toujours des personnages
qui sont debout qui sont beaux d'être
debout que j'essaye de de raconter dans
l'ordre dans leurs forces et dans leur
ténacité et c'est le cas par exemple de
mon inspecteur effectivement le monde
autour de lui est totalement assez
anxiogène et est sombre mais c'est vrai
que l'obstination avec laquelle il fait
son enquête par exemple pour moi c'est
une source d'optimisme c'est à dire que
ça compte pour lui de rectifier
ce déséquilibre incarné par le meurtre
ça compte de chercher la vérité il
pourrait décider que finalement tout ça
n'a plus aucune importance vu l'état de
délabrement général du monde non il y là
c'était fois encore en quelque chose qui
est qu' il est important de rapport au
serment qu'il a fait aussi vis-à-vis du
mort de dire ben je vais aller jusqu'au
bout de cette enquête et ça on fait de
lui finalement un personnage qui reste
debout qui reste accroché à ses valeurs
et puis dans ce monde un peu déshumanisé
que vous racontez lui il reste
profondément humain il aime il désire il
trahit aussi se réfugie ça c'est des
choses qui sont inaliénables ce qui a
existé une fois fait partie des archives
indestructible écrivez-vous en citant un
pote ben oui c'est la question de la
mémoire j'essaye de faire en sorte que
le lyssois traversée de manière un peu
souterraines par cette question là il
est il est flanqué d'un autre personnage
avec qui fait un tandem qui est un
personnage féminin beaucoup plus jeune
que lui qui appartient à une autre
génération et qui n'a pas sa mémoire lui
il vient d'un monde qui est la grèce et
il se souvient de tout ça et ça le rend
ça le rend à la fois sûrement très
mélancolique mais en même temps riche et
c'est un enjeu important pour moi dans
le livre c'est aussi une question sur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'eux des mondes
passé est ce qu'on décide que on avance
en les oubliant ou est ce qu'ils peuvent
être une source de richesse de savoir et
sauf que dans ce monde là le monde passe
alors on avait choisi j'imagine n'ai pas
choisi la grèce par hasard à travers
c'est bien sûr prend la crise de la
dette dans le livre est la grèce comme
d'autres pays est un pays qui a fait
faillite et donc a été racheté par cette
firme mais qui est une des firmes qui
contrôle le monde qu'est ce que vous
vouliez raconter avec ceux avec cette
graisse là le fait qu'elle n'existe plus
mais qu'effectivement elle est un refuge
pour ce personnage une des questions
c'est la question de la privatisation je
pense que le monde d'aujourd'hui déjà à
voir avec cette question là jusqu'où on
met le la frontière vis-à-vis de cette
espèce de tendance à la privatisation de
toute chose est ce que ce qu'il est ce
qu'on décide qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre de services ou de deux
choses qui ne peuvent pas être
privatisée parce que parce que c'est
pire s'ils le sont donc là moi je vais
jusqu'au bout c'est l'idée qu'un pays
tout entier seraient achetés pour
l'instant on n'a pas eu le cas de figure
est d'ailleurs je pense que ça
n'intéresserait pas les grandes firmes
mondiales parce que c'est plus de
problèmes qu'autre chose mais mais on
est plutôt dans un cas de figure
actuellement où les privatisations se
font par morceau regardez le port du
pirée qui a été rachetée totalement
remodelée
donc voilà c'est cette question là y
compris dans nos vies d'ailleurs
jusqu'où on met la frontière entre vie
privée et vie professionnelle c'est des
questions que chacun d'entre nous se
posent on sait que c'est devenu
compliqué de mettre une frontière dans
des enseignes est ma journée de travail
est terminé pour beaucoup de gens cette
frontière est devenue de plus en plus
poreuses à cause beaucoup des moyens de
travail qu'on a c'est à dire des écrans
de la disponibilité permanente qu'on
devrait avoir vis-à-vis du travail je
crois qu'il est question un petit peu de
tout ça aussi c'est plus anecdotique
mais dans la vie d'un écrivain quand est
ce qu'on dit j'arrête de faire
travailler mon cerveau à bannu jamais
nous jamais mais nous on savait dès le
début
justement vous toutes ses forces que
vous décrivez dans ce livre qui sont
donc une version peut-être voilà un très
fort cdd pente sur laquelle on glisse
collectivement qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui
vous donne l'impression de quelque elle
quelle force de résistance vous vous
vous inspire on parlait du fait de se
tenir debout est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres oui je pense qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de comment dire il ya il
faut pas noircir le tableau par rapport
notamment puisqu'on est là on parlons de
notre pays il ya énormément de choses
qui sont belles qui ont été construites
dans le dans le temps je je je pense à
mon domaine d'activité la culture
la pays la france est un pays quand même
très beau de ce point de vue là il ya
énormément de choses qui ont été
construites je pense aux livres la loi
lang à la au fait qu'on a désigné
justement cet objet livre comme un objet
qu'il n'était pas un objet anodin
vis-à-vis du commerce les librairies ne
sont pas des lieux de commerce normaux
au sens où ils sont protégés ou
sensoriel la loi du prix unique ces
choses là sont pas toujours su mais mais
c'est des petites et des petits détails
extrêmement important qui résistent mine
de rien à la grande commercialisation de
tout comme si tout était une paire de
chaussettes ou un paquet de je ne sais
quoi non il ya des il ya des objets
qu'il faut traiter différemment et je
pense que de ce point de vue là en
france et en europe on a quand même
encore ce souci qui nous est d'ailleurs
qui est un héritage la question c'est
d'arriver à maintenir cette culture là
qui est la nôtre vis-à-vis des nouvelles
formes de consommation culturelle et là
c'est les grands enjeux vis-à-vis des
plateformes de tout ça c'est la bataille
de demain et d'après demain oui voilà
résistant il ya plusieurs centaines de
livres qui sont sortis en cette rentrée
littéraire il ya de quoi il fait partie
de ma sélection personnelle chien
cinquantaire laurent gaudé merci
infiniment d'être rayonnant en parlait
ce matin dans paris direct pour mais
quand vous voulez je continue et ce
après la pause avec damien coq et à
toutes
[Musique]